25 years ago the United Nations
established an international scientific
body known as the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change or IPCC it's job
is to provide world leaders with the
best available information about how
climate is changing and what could be
done about the problem the IPCC has
issued reports about every six years and
a scientific understanding of the issue
has grown so has the size of the reports
and the number of experts involved in
producing them to make forecasts about
how quickly the globe will warm and how
the pattern will vary by region
researchers use computer climate models
that simulate the various elements of
the Earth's atmosphere and oceans the
resolution of those models has improved
by a factor of 10 over the past 25 years
allowing for much more refined
projections of how the climate will warm
researchers are now good at modeling the
current climate but they're still not
sure how sensitive the earth will be to
rising atmospheric concentrations of
greenhouse gases like carbon dioxide in
fact the estimates of such climate
sensitivity have not changed much in 25
years
but the IPCC has grown much more
confident over time that humans are
causing the bulk of the recent warming
and that without major reductions in
pollution from fossil fuels earth's
temperature will continue to rise check
out nature calm for the full story